(audience applauding)
- As a matter of fact, I was so nervous
if there is no one in this room, (laughs)
(audience laughing)
but...
Oh, amazing.
Thank you for your coming.
I am Se-hoon Oh, the Mayor of Seoul.
Before we begin, let's have
some time for ice breaking.
I prepared pop quiz about Seoul.
Of course, we prepared
some gift for the winner.
Let's start.
Okay, the first quiz about Seoul, 629.
It's a little difficult.
For your information, it is
related to the history of Seoul.
Okay.
- [Audience Member] Historical landmarks?
- Historical landmark,
oh, I'm sorry. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Okay.
- [Audience Member] Years that Seoul
has been the capital city of South Korea.
- Okay, she's very smart.
(audience applauding)
And last, four.
It's related to my
political life. (laughs)
Okay. Okay.
(audience member speaking faintly)
Okay. Thank you. (laughs)
I served four terms for now.
Okay, thank you.
Let's start the lecture.
It's enough icebreaking, yeah?
(audience laughing)
As you can see here,
my political life has been
full of ups and downs.
The green part, two
part, is my mayor's term,
and the yellow part is
my political absence.
Interesting.
To make a long story short,
there is 10 years of political absence
between the two times of mayor's term.
When I began my mayor's term
for the first time in 2006,
I was focusing more on
making Seoul more attractive.
But after 10 years of absence, you know,
I was doing my volunteer work
in Peru and Rwanda for one year
and I realized I had to do
more for the needy people.
You are looking at the
current vision of Seoul,
but today I'm here to tell you
how and what we do to
help the needy in Seoul.
Do you know Korea is very famous
for the speedy industrialization
and democratization?
This picture shows us some symbolic aspect
of every advanced
country, including Korea.
The serious gap between
the rich and the poor.
The problem is the rich get richer
and the poor get poor even more.
The discrepancy becomes
bigger and bigger day by day.
Frankly speaking, the
fact that I was selected
as Champion Mayor for inclusive
growth by OECD recently
gave me such a rewarding feeling.
But at the same time, I was
also surprised to find out
that OECD knew exactly what I was doing.
As a matter of fact,
there are so many policies
for the needy people,
but today I'd like to
explain a few major policies
for the socially neglected.
This is the first solution
for the polarization issue.
Don't you think the start
line should be fair?
Everyone in this room knows
the importance of education.
In Korea, however, students
need to get extra help
from the private sector,
so-called crammers,
in Korean, Hagwon,
to go to better college.
This is the main culprit
of the big discrepancy
between the poor and rich.
So it hit me, how can I
help those poor students?
This brought me to the
academic assistance program
called Seoul Learn.
This assistance program
provides the needy students
with famous instructors, online lectures,
studying materials for free of charge,
along with collegian mentors.
So we are trying to increase
the number of participants
for the program next year.
We've done it a little over a year now
and it has produced fantastic results.
A total of 461 participants
entered universities
through this program this year.
I strongly believe that if
I can change even one life
through this program,
that money is worth every penny
and I will not spare
any money for doing it.
This clip shows the effect of Seoul Learn.
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
(uplifting music)
(pupil's parent speaking Korean)
(everyone laughing)
(everyone applauding)
- How do you feel about the clips?
It's such a rewarding experience to me,
and I know there is someone
like this in this room.
Here comes the real deal
for the socially neglected.
It will change all the current
welfare system forever.
If this safety income
system becomes successful,
all the current welfare system
you know might be antiquated.
In the current welfare
system for the poor,
even if you have opportunities
to work more and earn more,
you hesitate or you can't work
because the minute you work more
than the government's set limit,
you will lose all the right to be aided.
So in the current system,
people will not want to work
more and make more money.
They would rather stay in
the cycle of being poor
and not work anymore.
But in the new welfare system
that I am experimenting now,
people in the poor boundary
will want to work more
and earn more.
This is the comparison picture
between the current welfare
system and Safety Income system.
Once they are selected
as help needing people,
we will monitor how much
they make every month
and supplement them
with the money they need
if they don't make enough money.
And we will stop giving them extra help
if they make enough money to leave.
But even though they are not
provided with extra money
because they worked harder,
their status of getting
help doesn't change
until they actually graduate from it.
This kind of experiment is
very common in many countries,
many cities, including Seoul.
This is the outcome of the past
one year of the new system.
There is a picture of professionals
commenting on our experiment.
Now let's talk about
the medical care system.
At this point in time, I
think I need to say something
about Korea's healthcare system.
I can dare to say that our
system is far better than yours.
(audience laughing)
Please don't kill me for this.
(everyone laughing)
In our current healthcare system,
the richer pay more and
the poorer pay less,
but the poorer get far
more medical benefit
from hospitals and doctors' offices.
Even with all this benefit,
as mayor of Seoul, I'm trying
to build more city hospitals
for the people who are in need of help.
This policy gives me another pride.
Nowadays, people do not starve to death
because our government is
taking such good care of them
in terms of food.
In my opinion, at this point in time,
we need to do something
about their will to survive on their own
because it's far more
important than the food.
I've tried to give those homeless people
the opportunity to take some
liberal arts related courses
at colleges.
Upon finishing the program,
they will be treated the same way
as ordinary college graduate,
the same graduation suit and
the cap and everything else.
Believe it or not, about 70%
of participants in the program
survived the courses and left the colleges
with ever higher self-esteem.
Yeah. Now let's take our
attention to the world.
You know we had a horrible
conflict with North Korea
about 70 years ago.
If we hadn't received help from the UN,
I wouldn't be standing here
and talking to you like this now.
We can't forget the very
much needed enormous help
from other countries at the time.
And we are the only country in the world
that had help from the world before
and is giving the help
back to the world now.
This aid money we gave
wasn't much in the beginning,
as you can see.
But as of this year,
we are increasing the amount
of aid money dramatically
and also, at the same
time, we are sending out
more volunteers to the world.
You know, I'm one of those believers
that it's far better to help the needy
by teaching them how to fish
and not just giving them a fish itself.
What a coincidence,
the initials for Knowledge Sharing Program
are the same as Korea Sharing Program.
I hope this transformation of Korea
can give inspiration and courage
to many less developed countries.
This is what we are doing to
help underdeveloped countries
become more self-sufficient
by growing rice more productively.
This is possible
because Korea could develop
easier rice to breed
to survive in destitute
African countries like Rwanda.
We are making every effort
to solve the starvation issues in Africa
by developing new rice breed,
and it has been very successful so far.
I myself stayed in Rwanda
for six months in 2014.
At the time, I helped the
city government of Kigali
with the issues such as industrialization
and welfare systems.
While I was there,
I was able to witness a
highly successful case
of growing rice more effectively
in the remote village of Musimba.
In the new village movement,
so-called Saemaeul Movement in Korea,
about five volunteers worked together
as a group for a few years.
These volunteers led dramatic changes
in the mindset of the villagers.
They took the initiative and
set examples for the villagers.
The locals slowly but surely
learned how to grow rice
and, finally, they realized
the true meaning of diligence,
self-aid and cooperation.
These three principles,
diligence, self-aid and cooperation,
are the spirits of the Saemaeul Movement
that were the fundamentals
of Korean development.
On the other hand, this
is sharing knowledge
and experience of Seoul.
We are sharing our knowledge
and experience with 61 cities
in 35 countries.
These are various examples
of sharing our best
practices around the world.
According to the news, quite a few cities,
including the city of New York,
is benchmarking our way
of processing food waste,
which is being turned into
fertilizers, animal feeds,
and sources of energy.
In Seoul, you can pay for one low price
of public transportation
and you can take the subway or buses
as many times as you want.
Actually, two weeks ago,
I announced a new policy
of unlimited use of various
transportation systems,
including buses, subways, and bicycles,
and in one year, river bus,
for only $50 a month by
benchmarking Germany.
Its name is Climate Companion Card.
As you all know, Seoul is
a world famous smart city
with stronger infrastructure ever now.
There's no question about that.
And last year, we launched
the Seoul Smart City Prize.
So far, 240 cities, corporations,
and organizations around the world
have applied for the prize.
And shortly after I return to Seoul,
the World Cities Summit
Mayors Forum will be held
to award the prize.
At last, this is the last
page of my presentation.
Can any of you tell which one is me?
Yeah, this is me.
I was seven years old
and I was with the hoodlums
in a poor neighborhood
where I used to live in.
Can you guess why I'm so
crazy about going together
with the socially neglected?
As a matter of fact, two days ago,
I and the mayor of New York, Eric Adams,
met and drank together.
(audience laughing)
And at the time, we found
out many common things
about our childhood background.
At the time, he told me his mother said,
"Hard time makes strong men."
I totally agreed with him.
It's one of main theme of
today's lecture, I think.
(audience applauding)
Actually, today's theme was
a little serious, isn't it?
So I prepared a video clip,
one-minute shot about Seoul.
(upbeat jazzy music)
(train chugging)
(crowd cheering)
Thank you.
Thank you for your listening.
(audience applauding)
- So thank you, Mayor Oh.
Let me test the microphone first.
Can you hear me okay?
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- Okay, good.
It's a real honor to be with you.
My name is Erik Harms,
I'm a professor of anthropology here.
I specialize in urbanization
and Southeast Asia
and have spent a long time
working in Vietnam myself,
so I was very pleased to see
the interest that you have
in the developing world
and your contributions
to other cities.
But I wanted to ask you a question
about your emphasis on going together
with the socially neglected.
One of the themes that
most people talk about
when they talk about Seoul
is high property prices.
And it's difficult to reconcile
the question of the socially
neglected with property prices,
and so one of the things
that many housing activists
will talk about is the need
to manage property prices.
- Yeah.
- On the other hand,
oftentimes, those who think
about the national economy
and the development of the city,
some of the kind of images
that we see in the video here,
will also say that,
well, actually managing property
prices is very important
for the stability of the
economic development.
So I'd just like to ask you,
what do you think about how to manage
the property price issue,
especially in conjunction
with what you were talking about today
with the socially neglect?
- Okay. I understand.
I think it's just supply and demand issue.
Actually, for the last 10 years,
of course, it's another mayor's term,
(everyone laughing)
not my term.
At the time, he has a
kind of political status
about the real estate,
housing, anti-redevelopment,
rebuilding the houses.
So because of the policy at the time,
the price of houses are increasing
and increasing day by day.
I think it is very important
for us to supply enough houses.
So after I became the mayor again,
I started to supply enough houses
through rebuilding and redevelopment,
because there is no vacant
spaces within the city proffer.
So if we want more supply of new houses,
we must demolish old houses.
And instead of that,
we must build some more houses speedily.
It's the most important solution.
Of course, there are so many reasons
of high price of houses,
but this, in this short time,
I can't explain all the reasons.
First of all, the most important
thing is supply of houses,
and I'm making every effort
to supply the new houses.
- Thank you.
I'll shift to another question.
And by the way, after
I ask a few questions,
we'll be opening it up to the audience
for other questions as well.
Another topic that one
immediately encounters
when one thinks about
modern day South Korea,
Seoul and modern day
South Korea as a whole
is the concern about
declining fertility rates.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
(audience chuckling)
It's very serious.
- It's very serious, right?
And some scholars have speculated
that some of the meteoric rise of Seoul,
like South Korea's
economy over the past year
has been related to demographic change
and, in fact, limiting population growth.
- Yeah.
- But now,
people are very concerned
about the future.
And so how do you imagine balancing that
in a thoughtful way?
- It's too tough question
because, as you know,
there is no right answer
about the phenomenon.
Let's ask to young people. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
Why... (laughs)
Actually, there are so many reasons,
but I think education,
the cost of education is
very high in my country.
Actually, as I told you,
Koreans are very interested in education.
Education is all,
so they don't spare their money
to educate their children.
So, many Korean young people
feel that the cost of
education is too high.
So the first solution is government
or Seoul Metropolitan
Government must help them
to educate effectively, efficiently.
But as you know, it is almost impossible,
so we are making every effort
to help to educate their children.
Anyway, immigration.
Immigration is a kind of solution.
It's very sensitive issue.
So in Korea, I do not mention
about immigration. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
It's very sensitive.
But recently in our country,
the issue of immigration
is emerging as a solution.
It's very beginning stage of
talking about immigration,
but it start, it start.
Maybe in one year, two years,
many Koreans will agree with
the solution of immigrant.
And moreover, the foreign students,
there are many foreign students,
especially Southeastern Asian countries.
There are so many foreign
students in Korea.
As I told you, there are so
many universities and colleges,
54 universities.
So we are considering
about giving them better
to settle down in Seoul.
It's very beginning stage of talking,
but it's start.
I think it's second solution.
- So I'll have one more question
before I open it up to the audience.
I have other questions if it gets quiet,
but I doubt it'll be quiet
in this great audience.
The last topic I'd like to raise for you,
you mentioned some of the
innovations that you have
for addressing the environmental crisis
that the globe is facing.
And I have a colleague
here at Yale, Karen Seto,
who's in the School of Environment.
And one of the big
discoveries that she's made
and has been sharing with
the world is, you know,
we tend to imagine that cities
are the opposite of
the environment, right?
But in fact, cities themselves
play a very strong role
in some of the global climate
solutions that we can have
because cities have the capacity
to bring people together to...
Although the city itself may have
certain ecological challenges,
it can reduce environmental
footprints on a larger scale.
Cities can be the space where one can have
very strategic design interventions
to solve the climate issues,
and so on and so forth.
You mentioned in your
talk about the innovation
with the metro card,
but clearly there's other things.
And one of the things that people notice
when they visit Seoul is they
expect it to be only city
and then they see this kind of
very interesting integration
with green space and city space
that is actually quite well done.
So I wondered if you
could tell our audience
about some of the successes
that you see in Seoul
and also some-
- Oh, success.
- Some of the challenges that
you think need to be addressed
and what are some of your ideas?
- Yes.
Frankly speaking, it is very difficult job
for every mayor in the world.
Actually, this visit to New
York is for the meeting of C40.
C40 is the mayors forum in the world
to solve the climate crisis.
At the steering committee,
when I attend the steering committee,
I reported three experiences,
three issues in Seoul.
First, yes, I mentioned
today the waste separation
and recycling,
it very successful case.
And second, as I told you,
I introduced the Climate Companion Card.
And for your information,
it's for the tourist
and foreign people also.
It'll be very useful, I think.
And third was the eco-mileage system.
Actually, 10 years ago, in my
first term of Mayors of Seoul,
I started, initiated
the eco-mileage system.
As you can guess, so large.
Citizen of Seoul can reduce
the energy and tap water,
it will be, accumulate as a point
and they can use the
point as a kind of money.
So it was very successful policy.
As far as I remember, from 2005 to 2022,
we can reduce the CO2, (laughs)
CO2 about 9.2%.
It was very successful trial
and very successful initiative,
so I reported the successful
case to the mayors of C40.
As you know, the CO2 is
produced in the buildings
and transportation in
city, especially city.
So general energy buildings
are very important
and low-emission vehicles
are very important.
The two solutions are
very important in the city
because there is no factories
in the city like Seoul.
So our ambitious goal is
reduce 30% of CO by 2030,
70% by 2040,
and 100% by 2050.
- Do you plan to be mayor that long?
(everyone laughing)
To see it through?
- Yes, of course. (laughs)
(audience laughs)
Yes, it's...
Anyway, it's very ambitious goal,
aggressive goal of Seoul
Metropolitan Government.
Frankly speaking, (laughs)
yes, I agree with you.
- Well, thank you for
entertaining my tough questions.
I wanna now open it to the audience.
I believe we have
microphones on either side.
And if it gets quiet, I have questions,
but I hope I don't have to ask them.
I think we can start on this side.
There's a person right there.
- [Audience Member] I just
wanna say thank you so much
for this talk today, it's meant a lot.
And personally, I thought your philosophy
in terms of helping the
economically marginalized
very interesting.
And I just wanted to ask,
how are you planning on
implementing that philosophy
in terms of socially marginalized groups
such as women and gender
minorities in Seoul?
And what initiatives can
we look forward to in Seoul
in the coming years for...
Oh, sorry, for women
and gender minorities.
- [Mayor Oh] I think
your English is too fast.
(audience laughing)
- [Speaker] Oh, I'm sorry.
- So I need some help from...
Ah, it's very sensitive question.
(audience laughing)
As a matter of fact, my
party is conservative party.
- [Audience Member] Yep.
(everyone laughing)
- Of course, women, women's case, I...
10 years ago, I started
the policy for the women.
The initiative's name was For
Women's Happiness project.
So, for instance, I made
the women only parking lot
in the basement,
and there are so many policies for women.
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
(Mayor Oh and audience laughing)
It's my answer. (laughs)
- [Erik] Would you like
to call on people yourself
rather than-
- Okay. Yeah, okay.
Yeah.
Yes, you.
(audience member speaking faintly)
(everyone laughing)
- [Audience Member] It's my great honor
that I can ask you a question.
I'm a postdoc in Yale University,
and I'm also father of one daughter.
So before I coming
here, I'm thinking like,
after like five or six years,
I may go back to Korea.
But nowadays, it's my problem
because nowadays living in
Korea is too competitive.
Like buying the apartment or teaching,
education-
- I'm sorry about that.
(everyone laughing)
- [Audience Member] In addition to that,
living cost of Korea is too high, like...
Well, most of the Korean postdoc
want to be a faculty in Korea, I think,
but the thing is that the
salary of the faculty is too low
to live in Korea. (laughs)
So I think many doctor or
postdoc would agree with me.
So this would be the
reason why many Korean
want to stay here.
I think you are,
you would be like next president candidate
on election next year, right?
(audience applauding)
So I really want to hear-
- Thank you.
- Know about your opinion.
And second is that, is similar thing.
So in these days, many
brilliant Korean students
just want to be a doctor,
so another major is kind of neglected.
So do you have solution about that?
Because it would be associated
with our country's development, right?
If everyone want to be a doctor,
who would study about the
engineering or other stuff, right?
So my question is simply two things:
how can you handle about
our competitive environment
or culture?
Second thing is that,
how can you serve those tactile origin?
I mean, everyone wants to be a doctor,
so how can you handle that question?
Can I deliver clearly?
(audience laughing)
Should I? Anyway, thank you
for understanding my English.
(audience applauding)
(Mayor Oh sighing)
(audience laughing)
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
(everyone laughing)
- Yes, it's very important case, I know.
Frankly speaking, I can't say solution
clearly in this room now,
it's very difficult issue.
So I will study about
that after this lecture.
I'm sorry.
- [Audience Member] Thank
you, Mayor, for coming
and spending time with us.
I'm a second year master's
student in public policy.
It's a widely known fact
that among selective welfare
and universal welfare,
more than a decade ago,
you stood on the side
of selective welfare.
But in today's slides,
policies such as public transport policy
that you're promoting,
it sounds like it leans more to towards
universal welfare now,
which makes me a bit be confused
about what your philosophy is.
So I would like to ask you
what's your take on it?
And please do remember
I'm a Korean citizen
and I have voting rights.
(everyone laughing)
(Mayor Oh speaking in Korean)
- Right? Understood? (laughs)
Thank you.
- [Lynn] Hi, thank you for your speech.
I'm Lynn, I'm an
undergraduate in Yale College,
I'm also an international
student from Korea.
Your mayoral election
was the first election I ever voted in,
so this is really crazy for me.
I just had, I think,
maybe an easier question.
My sister recently graduated
from ChungDahm Elementary School,
but you mentioned in your slides
that you were striving for more equity
in the education system,
especially between the
different social classes.
And a phenomenon that happens
in Korea is students often,
or families sometimes
lie about their address
in order to be zoned into
a different public school.
And that is very much the
case with (speaks Korean),
like my sister's school,
ChungDahm Elementary School.
So I was wondering what you were doing
in order to make the public
school system more equitable
considering that zoning
is such a big part of
the education system.
- Actually, you are Korean,
but your English is too fast.
(audience laughing)
It's difficult but I understood.
Actually in Korea education
is the (speaks Korean).
(audience laughing)
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
(Mayor Oh laughing)
- I should say-
- There are so many
Korean reporter at the end of this room.
- I should say we have
about five minutes left
before we break for the
reception afterwards,
so I think we can take two more questions.
Maybe we should get one from the far back
and then from this side after that.
So there's a hand very eagerly
raised in the far back.
- Can you (speaks faintly)?
- Yeah.
- [Zahramood] Thank you.
I'm Zahramood Ahmadi.
I am from Afghanistan and
I am honored to be here
as a research fellow in law school.
Actually, I visited Seoul in 2017
and found this city a varied
development and beautiful city.
I also talked with some
men and women in Seoul
and found some similarity
between the structure
of the family in Seoul
and in Afghanistan also,
but big differences between
the structure of the society.
I want...
I would like to ask about how you deal
with the issue of gender in Seoul,
in your country, I mean,
because there is a obvious different...
You know, there is a big
difference in my society
because we are facing gender
apartheid in Afghanistan,
but you as a developed
country has many achievement
in the aspect of gender.
Again, did my...
I am clear or I should
explain my question?
Yeah, I want to know
about the place of women
in the structure of the society,
how you share, I mean your government,
share the power with
the men in your country.
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
- [Zahramood] Thank you.
- [Erik] So last question. I'll
let you choose the last one.
- Dropped a hand here, hand here.
- [Claire] Hi, my name's Claire
and I'm an undergraduate student,
a Korean American
undergraduate student at Yale.
Just to build off the previous question,
I wanted to ask in a more societal scale,
do you believe that the
stigmatization of feminism
exists in Korea?
And if so, what do you think about it?
(Mayor Oh speaking Korean)
(audience laughing)
- Thank you.
So that brings our session to a close.
I wanna thank you Mayor Oh for joining us.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.